رمضان عطيه رمضان اهلا بك الحكومه
الاسرائيليه في اول الحرب كانت رفض
الطلبات اوكرانيا بمدها بالسلاح اليوم
يبدو الموقف وكانه يتغير كيف تتضح الامور
من ذلك ان الموقف الاسرائيلي منذ اندلاع
الحرب في اوكرانيا اسرائيل تلتزم اذا
الحذر في التعامل مع الوضع الحكومه
الاسرائيليه تقف بين من طريقه الحلفاء
السينما الولايات المتحده التي تحسها
وتمارس ضغوطا عليها لدعم اوكرانيا وبين
سندان العلاقات الاسرائيليه الروسيه
الاستراتيجيه بالنسبه لامن
حكومه بنت لابيد حارسه اندلاع الحرب على
سياسه الغموض من جهه ادانت هذا الاعتداء
ارسال مساعدات انسانيه الى اوكرانيا
والامتناع عن ارسال اسلحه الى اوكرانيا لا
سيما منظومه القبه الحديديه التي تريدها
كيف لتمنع القصف الروسي في الكواليس
اسرائيل عندما تدعما امم وراء الكواليس
لاوكرانيا لصد الطائرات المسيره الايرانيه
التي امطرت بها موسكو سماء اكياف لان
اسرائيل تعرف جيدا هذه الطائره مع وصول
حكومه نتنياهو العقيده الاسرائيليه بقيت
على حالها لكن ال- هناك امران امر الاقوال
وامر الافعال التصريحات الاسرائيليه جاءت
بمناسبه زياره اذا انطونيو بلينكن اسرائيل
تريد ان تطمئن الولايات المتحده ومن
وراءها اكياف بدمها لكن همم نتنياهو قال
سند دروسه همم ارسال اسلحه ولكنها ولكنه
لم يقل سنرسل اسلحه همم الكلمات هنا هنا
مهمه
وهناك الافعال اول ما فعله الرئيس الرئيس
الوزراء ببناء ثانيه هو الاتصال ببوتين
عندما تسلم الحكم وايضا اتصل وزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي بنظره لافراف الذي
باتمان على الساحه الدوليه هذه الخطوات
اثارت حفيظه وقلق وغضبك كاف التي سرعت الى
تخوف من انطوائي اذا همم اسرائيل على
لصالح اذا ااه موسكو هنا هنا هناك اذا
عقيده اخرى
نتنياهو لا يخفى علاقته الوطيده مع بوتين
وهو يريد ان يلعب دور الوسيط لان الغرب
وحلقه التواصل بين الغرب وبوتين الغرب فقد
هذا انقطع خط التواصل بين بوتين والغرب
هذا الدوري يلعبوا حتى الان رجب طيب
اردوغان همم رئيس رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيه من ثانيه ويريد ان يدخل على خط
الوساطه لابرامي اذن همم صفقه لي انهائه
الحرب سريعا لان هذه الحرب لا تصب في
مصلحته اسرائيل وبالتالي يمكن ان يلعب على
الوقت البدل الضائع وان يكسب الوقت لكي لا
يكون طرفا في هذه الحرب وانما يكون وسطا
طب وعلى طرفين شرق غرب كما يفعل اردوغان
طب لكن ما ابعد الاخرى لهذا الحذر
الاسرائيلي دائما من تسليم الاسلحه الكياس
كما تطلب كما يضغط ايضا الغرب اذا اذا
نستطيع ان نقول بان همم
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لا تريد ان تغضب
الولايات المتحده التي تضغط عليها لدعم
اوكرانيا في الوقت نفسه المصالح
الاسرائيليه الاستراتيجيه مع موسكو اولا
من ناحيه سلامه وامن المواطنين اليهود
داخل موسكو راينا بان الكريم لن اصدر في
الصيف الماضي همم قرارا باغلاق الوكاله
اليهوديه في روسيا وهي التي تعنى بشؤون
اليهود في روسيا والتي تعنى بشؤون ترحيل
اليهود الى اسرائيل هذه بالنسبه لاسرائيل
همم نقطه همم تحضير كبيره ارسلتها الى
اسرائيل لكي لا تدخل على خط ارسالي اسلحه
استراتيجيه الى اوكرانيا النقطه الاخرى هي
نقطه هامه جدا بالنسبه الى اسرائيل وان
روسيا تقعوا القوات الروسيه على الحدود
الاسرائيليه في شمال سوريا الضوء الاخضر
الروسي ضروري جدا بالنسبه لاسرائيل لكي
تقصف همم
مواقع او اهداف ايرانيه في لبنان في سوريا
وفي ايران وهذا من دون دعم موسكو لا يمكن
ان يكون بالاضافه الى ان القوات الروسيه
ضمان امني جدا لاسرائيل من احتماليه هجوم
لحزب الله او لايران وبالتالي الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي مرتبط جدا ب- اا
المصالح
بروسيا اكثر من ارتباطه مثلا باوكانيا
وهناك نقطه اخرى بان التواجد الروسي في
المنطقه في الشرق الاوسط اصبح اكبر من ذلك
الذي او نفوذها في المنطقه اصبح اكبر من
نفود الولايات المتحده حتى الان في ظل
سياسه التراجع التي استعملتها او
انتهاجتها حكومه اذن همم دونالد ت
وبالتالي عدم
استفزاز بوتين هو هي نقطه حيويه بالنسبه
تصب في ضمن او اطار الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي لذلك اسرائيل على الارجح لن
تدخل طرفا
في هذه الحرب لا في اطار دعم اوكرانيا
مباشره ولا في اطار الدعم او استفزازي
روسيا من جهه اخرى شكرا لك رمضان ايضا على
وقفه مع